we do continue our series in your
neighborhood this morning and it is
nate's turn indeed he is up as bianca
just mentioned
in the far northwest valley but this
time he's not centennial bowling he's
centennial
sitting and reporting today nate is
exploring the neighborhood of centennial
hills
near the centennial bowl and he has
zeroed in on a real
hidden gem in the northwest valley good
morning nate look at you with your desk
hi hey alex hey oh man it's beautiful
out here it's a little bit breezy
almost on the cool side but we're near
the 95 in the centennial bowl
it's a little village called centennial
springs and it's
tucked away in a cozy spot east of the
95
and south of durango and farm road
even though norman rockwell lane where
we are is only a couple of blocks long
there's as much going on here as any of
rockwell's famous paintings of americana
from restaurants and residential to new
mixed used construction
there's also a park at the end of the
street named after one of the most
prominent citizens of the early days of
las vegas
cp pop squires many of the buildings
here have businesses at the street level
and apartments in the upper floors
so that park is down at the end of the
street and we've got lots to show you
about this little neighborhood
throughout the morning hours from the
nearby city of las vegas community
center in ymca
to a bicycle shop that has not only
survived the pandemic but is thriving
as people look for ways to get out of
the house and explore
this vibrant area that we all call home
john alex we've got lots to talk about
and it's good to be with you here early
in the morning not a whole lot of
company it's just me and armando and a
couple of cars driving by but we'll talk
to you guys in the next half hour
well i hope someone shows up and gets
you some coffee yeah that won't last
long nate
thank you so much we'll see you coming
up here at five o'clock
so nate will have much more all morning
long for us from centennial hills all
morning long
and every tuesday we're taking you on a
trip around the valley to highlight the
people and businesses
in a different local neighborhood it's
been a really fun series so don't go
anywhere nate we'll have a lot more
coming up